(dramatic music)
You've been shot five
times for your country,
and you can't even afford to
send your kids to college.
We finally get to use our
skills for our own benefit.
All right, let's do it.
(upbeat rock music)
People describe seeing an entity
that takes on a form of your worst fears.
Oh my god.
What are you looking at?
What did you see?
We're going on the trip now.
It's going to be rough.
But under no circumstance are you
allowed to take off your blindfold.
Every contact we've had with the outside
has brought us death.
Everybody has a dark side,
some of us are better at
hiding it than others.
Oh, martini time.
I'm sure it's five o'clock somewhere.
Oh my god, did you just come up
with that cliche all by yourself?
He's such a brilliant man.
I mean I've played through some of these
emergencies before,
and she disappears for quite some time.
My god, you're such a nerd.
I study the marriage of space and time.
You don't realize what lies ahead.
This is going to be a very heavy feat.
We're going to fight this mess together.
My name is Stephen Hawking.
One never knows where the next
great leap forward is going to come.
(dramatic techno music)
This place is real isn't it?
We were born by a sort
of chemical madness.
A willingness of the heart
that burst thunderously upon us all.
Are you wanta sit on
the sidelines and watch,
or do ya want to play ball?
Play ball
Is it good enough for ya?
We don't do what we love
then we wouldn't exist.
Time kid.
Viktor Drago, son of Ivan Drago,
who infamously killed Apollo Creed,
appeared today to issue a challenge.
Now you know what you're fighting for.
First things first,
any man here that wants to walk away
can do so knowing their the best of us.
But it's gotta be now.
You cannot go back to your
normal life after tonight.
You guys need to own the fact that
what we're about to do is criminal.
(laughing)
If we wanted something we just took it.
If anyone complained twice
they got hit so bad believe me
they never complained again.
Murder was the only way that
everybody stayed in line.
You got out of line you got wacked.
Everybody knew the rules.
(plane engine roaring)
(glass breaking)
Hey look I don't want to sell it to you.
Its too ugly for that.
When your fighting in your own back yard,
your fighting for your family.
And for them this is just some place,
but for us, this is our home.
Peter Pans gots kids.
Jesse James Hook.
Fueling spawn, how I despise them.
What do you want old man?
Just you.
You need a mother very very badly.
Daughter, the path will not be easy.
The world outside is lifeless.
But I made you into the woman that you are
so that we could do this together.
This facility was designed
to give humanity a second chance.
There's a droid here.
Their guest has not been
entirely truthful with us.
Your whole life I've taught
you to see the bigger picture.
Everything I do is to protect you.
Suru, my beautiful boy.
I had another family.
What happened?
(mumbles)
I was lost.
(train whistly blowing)
I have to find my way back home.
What if you do find home
and their not even there?
And you just keep searching.
I'm going on an adventure.
True courage is about knowing
not when to take a life,
but when to spare one.
I've never been so wrong in all my life.
I don't understand what
their doing in my house!
(upbeat guitar music)
Welcome to Baywatch.
Our team is the elite of the elite.
We're the heart and
soul of this very beach.
Why do she always look like
she's running in slo-mo?
You see it too?
I'm Matt Brody.
This is the guy you think is
a good PR opportunity for us.
Give me some shots!
I'm ready to party.
Will you be my maid of honor?
Of course I will!
Let's go meet the rest
of the bridal party.
You must be Annie's fella?
I'm not.
He's not.
I'm not with him.
I'm glad he's single cause
I'm gonna climb that like a tree.
You better hold on tight spider monkey.
I'm not scared of you.
Well you really shouldn't have said that.
This isn't real.
This kind of stuff just doesn't exist.
It does in my world.
(gun shots firing)
Let's do our thing.
And the name is Shaft.
(glass breaking)
Yeah!
Oh!
John Shaft.
What are you doing?
I'm done workin for the man.
Ah
Junior get in the car.
Now.
Boom.
Ah!
It's just like Death in a Library.
What happens in Death in a Library?
They died.
That's why its called Death in a Library.
Ah.
(mumbles)
(car engine revving)
(glass breaking)
I didn't do it.
Of course you didn't
do it, you little twit.
Now you all remember
how scary your first days at school were.
You wanted cake you got cake.
Now eat it!
I'm fed up with all this reading.
Your a Wormwood.
You start acting like one.
(upbeat rock music)